since beginning of the pandemic he's
been teleworking
so he's been doing it from a restored
1976
trailer that he calls his mobile data
science lab
but he lives near ottawa so it's getting
kind of cold in there
so i'm not sure how much longer he's
going to last
everyone please welcome yvonne to the
stage
uh thank you as jared just mentioned i
work for the
department of national defense in canada
and today i'm going to talk to you about
how we are
increasingly using r for advanced
analytics
and also show you some examples of
projects that
my team has done recently
but before i know it was a recurring
team
in some of the previous editions of this
conference
uh but the military and defense
organizations in general
in many nations have a long tradition
of data analytics this is a picture of
dr george lindsay
he's considered to be the father of
military operations research
in canada and he's been leading the
organization
i worked for almost 20 years back in the
60s and the 70s
and just to give you an example of his
work uh
during world war ii george lindsay was
working on predictors
predictors are the fire control systems
that were processing signals from the
first generation of radars
and and using that data to predict the
motion of german aircraft
and shoot at them automatically so
predictors were initially mechanical
systems before before they became
electronic
and that's how uh george lindsay
described them
in a paper he wrote a few years before
he passed
he said today such problems would be
classified as
enter artificial intelligence
and uh he was right i think some people
would call that prescriptive analytics
or automated decision making but in fact
this was done
in the early 1940s is uh you know
pretty impressive another interesting
fact
uh george lindsay is also one of the
fathers of sabermetrics so
in the late 50s he was already
publishing papers on metrics that can be
used to compare
baseball players that's 20 years before
bill james started to publish books on
this
45 years before moneyball so that's also
very
impressive all that to say uh
that data analytics is not exactly new
to the defense community
now of course what constitute data
analytics is something that is
still a little bit debated some of my
colleagues
in dnd see analytics as this
new great big thing others based on
examples like the one i just showed you
are asking well isn't it the same old
thing that we have been doing
for 75 years and my answer to that is
always yes and no
because traditionally when a personal
analyst in d
and d apply their statistical expertise
or their scientific expertise to a
problem
they tend to produce a one-off analysis
that gets to be published in a report
or a paper or a briefing to a client
but data analyst and dnd rarely produce
models that are deployed in our
enterprise systems
to be reused on a regular basis or
models that will transform new data
coming in without having a scientist in
the loop to
process it or integrate it and to me
that's what
modern data science requires that's what
modern data analytics requires being
able to leverage
a fairly large amount of data that we
have in our in our systems develop data
products
that will ultimately live on those
systems
uh very often using cutting-edge tools
and cutting-edge statistical techniques
and that's exactly what my team is doing
you can see us here in a picture taken
before kovid
since then a few more people including
students have joined the team
and i will show you in a minute uh some
of the great work that
that they have been doing recently um
just to be clear
we're not the only data scientist in dnd
and we're not the only scientist in dnd
to do machine learning
but we are the only team to be embedded
with the chief data officers
organization
and we're the only team focused on
developing models
that will ultimately be deployed in our
enterprise systems
for routine decision support we don't
want our models
to be used exclusively by scientists we
want them to feed dashboards and
applications
that will be used in the recurring
fashions by planners decision makers
and that is really uh it's a bit of a
culture shift for us
in dnd um it's also a culture shift from
an i.t standpoint
uh to be really effective at doing that
kind of
enterprise data analytics you need the
right tools and the right infrastructure
and most of the tools that we have been
using historically in dnd for data
analysis
are not very well adapted to modern data
science
so when this team was formed a few years
ago we made the deliberate choice
to use almost exclusively open source
tools
for a number of reasons but i can
summarize these reasons maybe
into one as as wayne gretzky said
one of our great canadian heroes skate
where the puck is going to be
not where it has been so that's true for
aki that's also true for
it as well in the past
most of the data analysis that was done
in dnd was done using commercial tools
like these
but when it comes to developing and
deploying advanced analytics models
these days uh open to open source tools
like
r python spark are really the way to go
and i know i'm preaching to convert it
here but i think it's a message that we
need to keep relaying
within our government organizations it's
not just a question of getting access
to the most cutting-edge tools it's also
a question
of getting the best talent possible and
if you want to recruit
good talent you have to make these tools
available within your organization
and make them easy to use
that's easy to say of course but in
practice it's not so easy
there are often i.t roadblocks as a few
people i've already mentioned in this
conference
what has been a game changer for us in
dmd is getting access to commercial
cloud
access to cloud gave us amazing data
science virtual machines
sandboxes more computing power gitlab
servers to share our code
and also a means to deploy some of our
models into production
and the good news is that in the
government of canada
we have recently adopted a cloud-first
strategy in which cloud
is the preferred option for delivering
it services
so that will hopefully make the life a
lot easier
for all of the all of the data
scientists out there across the
government
okay so let me now show you three
projects
that my team has been working on
recently
i selected projects for which we have
used r
but i also try to select projects that i
think will
resonate the most with other government
departments that are represented
in this conference starting with
some of the work we have done in support
of operation laser
operation laser is the canadian armed
forces response to the pandemic
and a good part of it involves
supporting other government departments
and provincial governments requesting
military assistance
so for example over the last few months
the canadian armed forces
have assisted remote communities in the
north of the country
uh they were also asked to provide
assistance in over 50 long-term care
facilities
in ontario and quebec to do all kinds of
medical support and logical logistical
support tasks
but of course any good military
operation starts with
good planning and good intelligence and
at the very early stages of the pandemic
our medical intelligence staff
was already trying to predict how the
pandemic would progress
and where requests from requests for
assistance would
come from and although there are quite a
lot of models and dashboards available
to do that these days
uh back in february march there was not
that many tools available to provide
that kind of information
uh beyond maybe the dashboard from uh
john hopkins university
so what talia beach and my team
did is to produce this animated map of
the virus progression over time and
space
and this was done using r and using open
source data collected by the university
of toronto
open source shape files with postal code
areas from
statistics canada and back in april this
was probably the most geographically
detailed picture
of how the virus was progressing in
canada
so that map became very popular very
quickly within dnd
and even with other government
departments and it has informed some of
the planning
decisions related to a laser
initially the map was just an animated
gif uh
but a few weeks after we released italia
embedded the map into an r shiny app
which enabled users to have more control
on it picking an exact date
zooming in zooming in on a specific
region
and not only that italia added some
predictive component to the map so the
users can get an estimate of the number
of new cases
in each region up to seven days into the
future
so that's that's that was a pretty cool
project
my second project that i want to show
you is about
march madness unfortunately it's not
about basketball
it's about finance because you have to
note in the government of canada
fiscal years are ending in march and at
the end of the fiscal year
uh is when a lot of contracts with the
government are ending
uh that's when a lot of goods and
equipments are received
so it's not uncommon to see managers
spend up to 20
or even 30 of their annual budgets
during the very last month of the year
and that's why we call this march
madness
but often managers cannot spend all of
their remaining budget in march
because a contract may have been delayed
or because a piece of equipment
has not been delivered on time and when
that happens
it's often too late to reallocate the
money elsewhere
so in an ideal world you would like to
predict early in the fiscal year
say after just five of five or six
months
which managers will understand which
managers
may actually require more money and
reallocate your resources accordingly
problem is uh it's not that easy to
predict how much money managers will
spend
uh early in the fiscal year so what we
have done
here is try to leverage the huge amount
of historical financial data that we
have
in dnd to better understand some of our
spending patterns
and use these patterns to make
predictions
uh there are probably different
techniques to do that like time series
analysis for example
uh but the method we we initially looked
at
is to build a regression model that
predicts the amount spent
at the end of the year based on a number
of potential variables for example if
you plot
uh how much a certain manager has spent
at the end of the fiscal year against
how much he has spent
after only five months uh you see that
you know
there's clearly a relationship between
these two things over the years
and and you can exploit that
relationship you can do the same thing
with other variables how much money was
committed how much money was allocated
and you can build a
pretty good linear model out of that
which is exactly what uh cheri
gunasekara in my team
and he's on at this conference that's
what he has done
he built a regression model that he
implemented into a shiny app
um right now this shiny app is not
directly connected to our financial
system but it can take data extracts
from our financial system
and generate pretty good forecasts uh in
red there with the 95
95 confidence interval uh fairly early
in the fiscal year so this is just a
prototype
uh but we are working with our financial
branch to test it on different funds
with a view of deploying that kind of
statistical model
directly into our financial systems in
the future
my last example about the is about the
public service
employee survey and this is a survey
conducted every year
in canada to get the views of all the
employees of the federal government
about their workplaces so it's a fairly
comprehensive survey with over 180
questions
that covers different teams like
employee engagement
leadership workplace compensation and so
on
and the goal of the survey is really to
allow the government departments to
identify
what they're doing well and what they're
doing not so well
in terms of managing their people so all
the departments
have a close look at these results
uh every year and they develop action
plans to address issues
that are raised in this survey which is
good
but most departments at the moment are
still analyzing the results
in a very traditional fashion uh so for
example they build dashboards and they
look at where they're scoring high where
they're scoring low
how much their scores have changed since
the last survey
and obviously that's a natural place to
start
um but it's not necessarily the optimal
way of exploiting the data
uh because this day this survey has a
lot of questions
so it's often hard for the departments
or the department branches to figure out
what part of the results they really
need to focus on
um so one approach to that problem that
we have successfully
used in my branch of dnd is to do peer
comparisons
so for example if you take the score
obtained by a branch to a specific
question
and you compare it to those of all the
other branches in the government you can
quickly find uh if you are in the bottom
10
or in the top 10 percent of all the
branches
so that's a very simple approach uh but
it tells you
very quickly uh the kind of results that
you should be have a
closer look at and we have done
dashboards
to allow departments to do that kind of
analysis very quickly
but even with that kind of tools the
results of the survey are not always
easy to interpret or address because of
how certain questions are framed
for example one question of the survey
is
i am satisfied with my department and
people have to answer
on a numerical scale to what extent we
agree or disagree with that statement
so if a department gets a low score on
that question
uh how can you interpret that you know
how can you explain
what causes employee dissatisfaction and
more importantly
what can you do about it so
that's something we've tried to to
answer
as part of a project we did in
collaboration with the national research
council
we developed a new set of dashboards
using r
that first have a look at how the survey
responses are correlated with each other
so in this case we use a forced layout
algorithm in
r to visualize the correlation matrix
between the responses
and that allows us to spot very quickly
what are the
really central questions of the survey
for example question 44 i am satisfied
with my department
um that's right in the middle there
question 66
my workplace is psychologically healthy
question 26 i
am satisfied with the quality of the
supervision i receive
these questions are strongly correlated
to a lot of other questions in the
survey
and you cannot just look at them in
isolation
what you can do or however is to you
know if you get a low score to this
question
you can try to understand what are the
main influencers and
again there are means to do that in r
you can build a
causal graph that estimates the strength
and the direction
of the influence between different
questions so for example
in q66 my places my workplace is
psychologically healthy
uh you can see that's influenced by
question 65 responses
about awareness and mental health it's
influence
by also responses to question uh four
i have support to at work to balance my
work and my personal life or
question 54 my department works hard to
create a workplace that prevents
harassment
that's really interesting because it's a
little bit more clear
and it's more actionable i'm going to
give you another example that is even
more telling uh you can use a machine
learning approach
to do the similar kind of analysis if
you look at
question 26 i am satisfied with this
quality of the supervision i receive uh
which is a very central question in the
survey
you can train a random forest model to
determine what are the top predictors
of responses to that question and if you
look at the results it tells you that
the most important predictors
are the responses to q22 i receive
useful
feedback from my supervisor question 24
my supervisor keeps me informed about
issues affecting my work
question six i receive meaningful
recognition for work well done
and so on so again my point here is that
this kind of insight is useful
and it's sectionable and it can inform
action plans that will ultimately
improve the the general satisfaction of
employees
and we again we we develop dashboards in
r
and also using a combination of r and
power bi that make that kind of analysis
very easy and very quick to do
um so just before i finish very briefly
i want to mention
some of the other projects my team has
been doing recently using r
for example we've done work with
the royal navy about personnel
enrollment and selection
modeling uh we've done work with our
material branch on procurement cost
forecasting
uh we're doing some work with our nato
allies including the us
on predictive maintenance and also uh
we did some work recently on supply
chain forecasting and a bunch of other
exciting things
in other languages like like python and
and
and commercial tools but uh you know
that
there's a lot to be done in in data
science and we're not uh
we don't have any kind of shortage of
problems that we can work with
so on that note um i'd like to
thank you again thank you jared for the
invitation and uh
have a good day i love that we got to
see the trailer at the end there as if
the
statistics wasn't good enough we got to
see his trailer so that was uh that was
pretty awesome
okay as promised we are now going to do
the uh